mister x der mich eigentlich nur zwei
fehler gemacht und zwar einmal ist er
und ich glaube ich wirklich einfach aus
panik auf den server gibt leute bevor
die ganze sache eskaliert kurzem meine
meinung dazu warum meine meinung fragt
iran habe ich mit zwei beteiligten
relativ viel zu tun natürlich max ist
meine eigenen bruder lukas auch jemand
mit dem ich bezahlt eigentlich schon
verbracht hat und ich war zum zeitpunkt
dieser aufnahme oder das ganze passiert
ist auch dabei ich natürlich nicht in
der aufnahme hinweisen war verboten ist
aber ich war zu dem zeitpunkt anwesend
als die ganze geschichte passiert ist
was in meinen augen relativ wichtig ist
weil sonst die einzigen leute die
darüber reden diese die selbst betroffen
sind und die sind natürlich da
beeinflusst sagen ihre eigene meinung
deswegen möchte ich da als neutraler
beobachter als dritter quasi der dabei
war aber nicht selbst davon betroffen
ist auch was dazu sagen
und übrigens leute heute ist der achter
zwölfter das heißt man kann nur noch bis
heute mitternacht man merchandise
bestellen will dir also zum beispiel
noch bock auf dieses t shirt oder die
police ab die wir noch im store checks
dass auf jeden fall nochmal heute um
mitternacht schließt der ganze laden
wird sich ganzen dinge nie wieder geben
alcoa schlucht bewirbst den deutschen
durch ja aber ich hab das doch alles
selbst gemacht da kann man auch wirklich
mal wenn die bestellung des phase endet
noch kurzen hinweis dazu geben weil sie
nicht wissen wovon ich rede
er wisse nicht redet luca beim crafter
ist aus marmor ausgeflogen
ich betone ich mit so guten tote ich
bitte da gab es eine riesige aktionen
und darum ob das jetzt fair ist ob das
sein da wurden leute bestraft luca ist
gestorben der tod kann nicht rückgängig
gemacht werden
das ist total großes kunden moderne
springen da gerade auf und haben
überhaupt keine ahnung wovon sie reden
deswegen wollte ich auch meine meinung
dazu beitragen und meine sichtweise wie
sag ich jetzt dritter der weiber
arbeiter betroffen ist habe ich eine
wichtige perspektive
ich habe mir zu meinem skript
geschrieben dass er die ganze story noch
und vorne erzähle aber ich glaube ihr
wisst eigentlich was da passiert ist nur
noch mal ganz kurz vista monarchie
wussten wo maxime luca sind in dem
projekt und max luca wussten dass die
das wussten die beiden saßen da hatten
gerade auf folge aufgenommen wollten
noch eine folge auf dem modell der halt
abbauen
ich gedacht okay die haben jetzt drei
folgen produziert das sieht man ja in
der barocken wie wie vor produziert
haben haben aber noch keine davon frei
geschaltet was nach war oracle heißt
dass man nicht noch eine aufnehmen darf
man darf immer maximal nur drei folgen
produziert haben und dann haben sie sich
gedacht war geil alter die regel sind so
das heißt die haben drei vorproduziert
und sie haben ihre videos noch nicht
freigeschaltet
wir können jetzt drauf und die dürfen
uns nicht hinterher ja gefährden sie
gemacht haben bei der dass luca eine
verdammte sekunde zu früh geräumt ist
ich hab das ganze kultur live gehört und
dachte hey leute warum hat es jetzt so
eilig auf den server zu gehen wartet
doch abwartet doch ab bis sie wirklich
runter sind lukas problem bald einfach
die haben in der konfi geschaut in
dieser disco ort waren konnten wir sehen
okay mister x wird geklickt ok geil die
luft ist rein was sie nicht bedacht
haben ist das ein paar sekunden später
als minister morgan jones ist und
deswegen auch ein paar sekunden später
gekickt wird und die ganze so lächerlich
wenn du über zwei sekunden später
gewinnt wäre noch am leben
alles was jetzt passiert bis zum ende
der aufnahme kann man aber in den videos
sehen deswegen möchte ich da nicht
drüber reden springe mal zum ende der
aufnahme in der luca stört die jungs
beenden die aufnahme sind natürlich
selbstverständlich richtig ist weil sie
denken dass in dem moment sie unfairer
weise getötet wurden und genau diese
momente es war so lustig ging schon die
diskussion ab in dieser gruppe
scheinbar hat einen mega mega viele
leute nur darauf gewartet dass das
passiert und das quasi live verfolgen
und sobald luca tod war ja auch aber zu
ende war gegen die diskussion war luca
und max war in dem moment natürlich mega
sauer auf weil sie darauf vertraut dass
sie regeln beachtet werden und sie das
gefühl dass sie nicht beachtet wurden
die ganze diskussion als ich dann mehr
eben ist amor gewendet bei klar wurde
dass er doch irgendwie bisschen schuldig
ist aber irgendwann sind maxim luca aus
dieser gruppendiskussion ausgestiegen
haben wir die eigenes dinge war vor
allen dingen zu tun maximus mit mir
aufnehmen pipapo videos schneiden dann
gehen die ganze debatte mit diesem
statement wie es los dann hat lukas
themen wie hochgeladen dann hat mich am
ort gesehen hatten noch ein statement
ihr hoch beladen und luca sein altes
leben wieder auf ungelöst gestellt und
hat ein neues entschuldigung statement
video hochgeladen also ist alles total
confused verwerfungen und der einzige
grund dafür dass diese ganze sache so
ein bisschen eskaliert ist liegt darin
dass die beiden leute einfach
unterschiedlich sind
luca ist anders als mister moore und
denkt an dass minister monster modding
einerseits luca ich möchte mit diesem
video einfach darauf aufmerksam machen
dass es wirklich nur dieser kleinen
meinungsverschiedenheit liegt und dass
es keinen grund gibt aufeinander zu
hetzen und dass sie sich alle wieder
vertragen sollen in lukas erst im
statement video hat man gemerkt dass ihr
einfach diese pvp denkweise nicht hat
das ist ganz wichtig um zu verstehen
warum er sich so aufgeregt hat er denkt
wird einfach nicht so nach dem motto
okay man nimmt warum mehr oder weniger
ernst und man will irgendwie den anderen
was zeigen dass man es drauf hat im pvp
man mit anderen wikinger etwa rohr
entdeckt sie als jahr fakt vielleicht
überlebe ich eine folge ist am ort
ansatz ist ganz anders grundverschieden
ist er [ __ ] denkt hat wirklich so im
wettbewerb möchte zeigen dass er gut im
pvp ist dann möchte zeigen dass er am
töten kann von der macht auch aktiv jagd
auf andere luca max machen ja sowas
nicht also die haben einfach nicht
diesen pvp denken was aber gar nicht
schlecht ist weil wenn ein projekt alle
nur am geiern sinn alle treppen am
rechner dann würde es auf dauer auch
irgendwann einfach nur eklig bin beide
perspektiven wichtig in so ein projekt
überhaupt natürlich hat luca sich in
diesem video ein bisschen im ton
vergriffen hätte das alles bisschen
anders verpacken müssen hat er in dem
fall nicht gemacht hat sich denn dafür
war der video entschuldigte das alte
runtergenommen mit dieser entschuldigung
im nachhinein ist eine reaktion die
abzockerei laufen deshalb quasi so die
fehler di luca gemacht jetzt gehen wir
auf die fehler ein minister moore
gemacht hat müsste mich eigentlich nur
zwei fehler gemacht und zwar einmal ist
er und ich glaube ich ihm wirklich
einfach aus panik auf den server
geträumt ich kann das selbst
nachvollziehen warum ist man einfach im
kopf nicht da und man denke ich
besonders vielen darf man geht halt
einfach auf diesen server drauf also das
kann ich schon nachvollziehen das war
fehler nummer 14 nummer zwei und der
schwerwiegende behalte aber einfach dann
darüber zu lügen das hätte ich nicht
machen sollen weil diese beiden fehler
zusammen sehen auch als wär's absicht
es ist klar dass es dafür eine höhere
strafe als track gibt also was können
wir abschließend sagen beide seiten
haben fehler gemacht in dieser ganzen
situation luca hat falsch auf die ganze
geschichte reagiert misst der [ __ ] hat
davor schon seine fehler gemacht quasi
und dadurch jetzt das ganze
aufgeschaukelt mein blick auf die ganze
sache ist einfach okay zwei leute am
fehler gemacht ok passiert ja ja so was
kann man einfach passieren in so einem
projekt vivaro wo so viele leute so sehr
dabei sind wo auch die die eigentlich
nicht so pvp sind auch max im liga total
dabei sind jetzt den maxis video gesehen
wir geschrien hat als er gesehen hat
einige sekunden von dem gameplay
rausgeschnitten
nein das können nicht davon dass er
nicht dann interessiert ist unter diesen
alle 100 prozent dabei und da schaut man
sich manchmal die ganzen sachen hohe von
menschen an den rhein aus emotionen
deswegen wollte ich mit diesem video
erfragen noch mal dran erinnern leute
ruhig es gibt keinen grund sich
gegenseitig zu bieten es gibt keinen
grund sich gegenseitig zu beleidigen
oder dauerhaft zu hassen aber zwei leute
fehler gemacht und daraus ich diese der
ganze krempel [ __ ] entstanden und den
können wir uns auch ganz leicht wieder
weg denken wir einfach akzeptieren okay
lukat fehler gemacht ist amor hat fehler
gemacht und sehen wir drüber hinweg
jeder hat aus dieser ganzen sache
konsequent zu bekommen mit denen er
nicht ganz glücklich sein kann
luca ist toten dem projekt ist der mord
aber harte strafe ereilt also die ganze
sache ist eigentlich immer leute lasst
uns da nicht zu lange darauf rumreiten
macht er wirklich keinen sinn so ein
riesen großen theaters der sache zu
machen und daran wollte ich einfach nur
ändern mit diesem video